Brian from looking at your IMDB is it
true that Steel City was your first
feature or future you had done a few
shorts I think I did a couple shorts in
film school and then I was put in this
talent program called Fox search lab me
and a bunch of other directors and they
were cultivating young filmmakers so
they I did a short under that banner in
2002 within that time that John heard
okay great well then how did Steel City
end up going to Sundance tell us about
the story of just how it got in I mean
so many people that's their that's what
they shoot foreign yeah when I was
making the film I just wanted to I I
mean I knew it was gonna this is my
first film I was gonna it was either
going to be is gonna make or break me
that first movie and I just did my best
it's just as cliche as it sounds I gave
it everything I had I mean I used to lay
in bed at night and and whatever your
higher power God is I used to I used to
pray to God I'd be I would say if if I
can't do anything else in my life just
let this happen
let's Steel City happen I won't just let
this happen let me give me just give me
an opportunity because I was you know
working on the script and I had John
Hurt involved and you know I was relying
on the community of Alton I had
investors at Alton and then I teamed up
with a production company in LA and it
all came together in this very strange
way that I've never had an experience
like that since and that was back when
you know so it all came together we
shoot this movie I get a great cast I'm
in the middle of editing the film and my
appendix almost burst and I'm editing
and I'm so into the I'm so into editing
this movie and I don't go to the
hospital and I wait and then I get
violently ill so I go to the hospital
and I have to have my appendix - I
haven't happened ectomy and I'm like oh
man and so then that happens in the
middle of editing and then finished
editing the movie and I'm broke I have
no money so I start working in a
house and as a warehouse manager and
then that hole I never really thought
about Sundance that much because we
could submit it to Toronto a rough cut
and we didn't get in and you know the
thing in the voice in the back of your
mind says well if Toronto didn't accept
you then Sundance may not accept you but
they were repping another movie we had
not them we were working with a company
called traction media who was it was a
producers rep and they had a movie
called half-nelson that they that was
told they were in there very early on
that Half Nelson was in and they was
reppin they were repping Steel City as
well and it worked out they I got a call
that we were in so you're you're working
in this warehouse you've already you
edited the entire film movies done at
this but movies don't know yeah and and
you were gonna pass on Sunday and she
thought well if we don't get into I mean
I mean I knew I mean I would not pass I
mean obviously we will I was
enthusiastic about going but I I you
know I'm working a nine-to-five job to
pay my bills I'm not gonna I was proud
of the movie and and I didn't my
production company submitted the film so
I didn't do any of the paperwork and I
don't know where were you in your life
when you heard did you get a phone call
I've got a phone call in the in the
warehouse I was working in really yeah
saying are you gonna be around later and
I said I get off work at 5:00 it takes
me an hour to drive back home and my
producer said well they're gonna call
you when's a good time to call you I
said well I did want him to call me at
work so I said after 6:00 I'll be home
it's like at home and it's the day
before it's like 2 days before
Thanksgiving or maybe the day before I
got a call from Carolina Brisco and she
said would you would you like to go to
Sundance and I said to ski or for the
film festival and she goes no you're and
we want to include your movie and it was
great so then we went and and celebrated
so the job gives you time off
no I had the job let me go because I
told him I need to I need all this time
off to go to Sundance and my boss said
what do you what Sundance I said it's
kind of a thing for filmmakers and he
goes okay I mean and that was it
so you had to quit you yeah I mean there
was there was like it was like a mutual
departure right Wow
so you go you come back then what is you
you come back to Alton after I was
living in LA at the time so I go back to
Los Angeles and okay
taking these meetings and reading
scripts and playing the play in the game
and I guess what everyone does after
they go through an experience like that
and looking for my next project and then
one of your actors is given a nomination
for what it's at best supporting array
Barry got an Independent Spirit Award
for Best Supporting Actor which was
fantastic cause he's so great in the
movie and you know when you make a
low-budget movie and you ask these
actors who have been working since
before you were born who have been done
all this work you're so privileged for
them to come do your little movie for no
money I mean seriously it's a big deal
when you have people that believe in you
and they come they leave their home they
leave their family they go to a location
and they do your movie and when they get
recognized for that on a big scale it's
it makes it all worth it and they
realize that and they see that because
so many independent films that get made
that don't get recognized their due
recognition or their bad one or the
other but I was fortunate that I got
recognized and it was able to open that
door that yes I can work with these
people again they trust me so going back
to that those nights you know praying to
God whatever did you expect that all
this was going to happen I mean this is
this is pretty amazing for socially a
first-time feature filmmaker I know you
had the experience with the script lab
or the contest but I mean was that the
intention or you just really needed to
get the story out there was that more I
just needed some money to make my film I
was
figuring out a way of who would give me
an opportunity first time director I
mean I was young and I was figuring out
how can I start my career how can I what
what's it gonna take for me to get this
opportunity what am I gonna have to do
and I just wouldn't give up I mean I was
just that was when I was writing still
city I was working the graveyard shift
in a hotel in Century City and I was
writing the script longhand on hotel
stationery
I'm seriously I was writing all these
dialogue scenes I had to all this time
to kill I wasn't allowed to have a
computer I couldn't write the script on
the hotels in her face obviously so I
wrote the whole first draft on hotel
stationery I mean I had like 85 hotel
stationery sheets of just scenes and
dialogue I'll never forget that staying
up like in this my hotel outfit writing
steel city it's kind of wild to think
about
you